[Musique]
pour la quête à l' excellent qui gémit
tu bats d'auckland roseman bien sûr on
l'a reconnu les amis journée on est sûr
choix de merde point fr un site français
ont des contentieux la france est un
beau pays vous les baguettes sont bonnes
voilà c'est mal parti
on a déjà fait des trucs similaire en
gros c'est ainsi tout à chaque fois on
va avoir le choix entre deux trucs na
nana na na hey il faudra choisir la
réponse qui nous correspond et on aura
bien sûr le pourcentage de gens qui ont
choisi la réponse que tu as toi même
choisi voir si tu penses comme tout le
monde si t'es pas original ou s'ils
étaient différents des autres
ok la première pouvoir être invisible
mais devoir faire du bruit pour le reste
et c'est très très nul ou alors voyager
dans le temps mais tu dois rester sur un
tricycle très clairement voyager dans le
temps tu pinto tricycle tu mets un petit
moteur électrique si tu reviens de
vidéos noz man tu apprends comment faire
bîmes c'est bon t'es bien excellence
doit gérer vie de newman ou pas allez
hop le tricycle ben oui eh ben voilà
sang neuf pour cent des gens ont brûlé
xx est évident en plus sur ce modèle tu
possède un petit panier à l'avant qui
permet de mettre par exemple ton casque
louis produit un tricycle il faut un
casque sur la tête question suivante un
tatouage tribal ou un tatouage chinois a
a tué mais cauet tatouage tribal sont
vexés de ouf
franchement à toto chinois puisque
tribal hausse quoi mais malgré pour le
tatouage tribal mon gars c'est dangereux
c'est bon tatouage tribal c'est bien
s'aimer annoncé il est beau mais c'est
les goûts et les couleurs mais je trouve
ça tellement chaume le tribal quoi
c'était il ya tellement mieux dans l'art
abstrait à beaucoup mieux que ce à quoi
enfin bref c'est mon avis c'est mon avis
je respecte le vote même s'il est nul je
respecte poils de nez ou poêle d'oreille
non mais l'abus qu à mais dans les deux
cas cessé c'est dégoûtant ça les punir
poils de nez aux poils d'oreilles une
question existentielle que oh là là
franchement pour les oreilles au les
gens préfèrent avoir des gros poids est
de donner à merde
ah le con tu es quelqu'un ou être
ignorée de tous avoir une vie de merde
quoi on va tuer quelqu'un non on va
éviter à on va préférer est ignorée de
tous voilà + 1 789 personnes sont prêtes
à tuer quelqu'un pour ne pas être
ignorée de tous lui sinon faire ses
besoins dans une litière faire ses
besoins devant quelqu'un devant poutine
par exemple faire ses besoins dans
quelqu'un ce qu'aime le truc le plus
gênant du monde tu es seul tu en bas les
couilles faqiryar dans un pot ouzou dans
des toilettes aux unitaire c'est la même
nom dans une litière quattro a besoin
des gens prêts à face à dans des
toilettes mais devant quelqu'un et
l'intimité aller ou qu un mec incroyable
cyril hanouna ou une lampe roi bec
touche pas mal en pro à monga des
miettes dans le lit ou une étiquette qui
grave dans un verre cette [ __ ]
d'étiquettes la havre il ya des marques
qui ont fait vite qu est ce que tu peux
arraché à la main tous ces gens rails
avec des pointillés tu peux l'arraché
hugo quand tu la retire elle tenait
encore plus puisque c'est moins doux le
bout franchement les mettre dans l'imec
à 3 heures du matin une grosse prise de
conscience tu te lèves tu prends ton
petit des reason comme ça non mais c'est
vrai 53 cents jeunes présents dans le
cul qui grattent quoi c'est à chinon
ressembler à ribéry ressembler aux
frères post je faisais était si peut
être pire que de ressembler à ribéry
ouais mais après ferme ma gueule nov
ils ont fait une sorte de chirurgie
c'est sûr et certain même s'ils disent
non n'a pas fait ça alors que ribéry
c'est bien naturel à je sais pas ce
qu'il ya comme des beaux yeux ribéry
regarde sa mère a volé toutes les
étoiles du ciel est bien mis dans les
yeux pour avoir des yeux pareil
j'adorerais faire ça là je la fais à
toutes les vidéos franchement
ressemblant bogdanov mec à savoir un bon
sens près faire ressembler à ribéry par
contre vous avez pas le même métier
c'est-à-dire que vous gagnez pas des
millions et un footballeur accuse
zagallo de métier le même bon voire
l'eau des wc inspiré dans un pot
d'échappement franchement aspects dans
un pot d'échappement mec mon ventre
après quoi mais là je comprends pas voir
l'autre des blessés mac l'aude des wc
mais pas mais pas quand tu as mis ton
canard wc à hasnon alors l'eau la vraie
ou des wc mec mec alors patiemment tu
veux juste faire et c'est bon ça va plus
c'est fini ça a duré une seconde non
mais là je m'en vais pas lâcher
franchement je suis presque déçu par mon
pays je vais presque aller vivre en
bretagne au squeeze où cyprien
norman bas cyprien bah voilà comme ça
quand tu % des gens on dit pas s'ils
ouvrent ce site sont constipation
diarrhée bas le grand dilemme
je crois que jamais été consulté de ma
life c'est parce que ça fait gérés
constipation puisque tu mets un tu mets
une sorte de bon bah voilà tu mets un
suppôt dégueulasse et ça passe quoi tu
vois alors que dia remake si tu mange du
riz et ça passe quand même pas tu re
manche du risque passe quand même pas et
50 dans sept des gens bien sûr pensent
que la constipation et mieux je me sens
bien quand je suis dans la majorité ça
un phénomène social qui touche tout le
monde
tu as envie d'être dans la majorité tout
en voix la majorité des bulletins dans
la majorité donc tu dis qu'elle est pas
débile tout sens bien je suis un con et
sociaux ça vous dit vivre sans musique
où vivre sans téléphone sans téléphone
mais mec mais de tellement loin des
changements baptême les couilles alors
que la musique mon gars c'est tellement
la vie d'ailleurs petite anecdote mon
secret avant de tourner une vidéo pour
être de bonne humeur parce que je suis
pas toujours bonne humeur je me fera
toujours du bon pierre mémoires secrets
c'est d'écouter des musiques que
j'affectionne énormément ça me donne la
joie de vivre
je vous jure là par exemple et regardez
j'écoutais une musique juste avant
j'écoutais ça et j'étais comme ça ouais
je suis très heureux j'ai le meilleur
métier du monde
allez on tourne c'est parti hyper jeunes
un habile à ouzaï à mais comment
dellacqua zabi là franchement je dirais
quand même
nabila voilà je sais même pas pourquoi
mais bon là je en plus je suis pas la
majorité veut montrer quelqu'un être
immortel sur terre où vivent 20 ans une
planète extraterrestre pacifiste j'aime
bien le pacifiste pour t'orienter un peu
ton choix quand même ok tu te disais
ouais enfin peut être exagéré ses
pointes esclaves et mourir parce que les
mecs me tue quand tu tu mens et banale
son pacifisme tu fermes ta gueule moi
j'ai toujours pensé que est immortel ça
doit être terrible parce que si tu es le
seul à être immortel tu vois tout est
proche mourir les uns après les autres
tu vis plus au fait après ça même si tu
physiquement tu est immortel je pense
que psychologiquement tu es totalement
anéanti donc mieux vaut 20 ans je me
plais texte intéresse pacifiste voilà
aimé ça mais je m'en bats les gens qui
veulent être immortel c'est c'est
bizarre mais comme délire ta mère ton
père ta meuf ton frère tu as her vous
mourir oui ils sont pas immortels vont
mourir tu vas le voir mourir tu feras
quoi après tramway mais moi je suis chez
pas dans le fond ce logis c'est hyper
beau mais comme je le dis c'est hyper de
la merde fabriquer des maquettes pour
c'est pas sorcier mais qu on est sur un
métier exceptionnel
là tu l'a justement ce que tu penses tu
regrettes
l'augmentation n'est pas dit pourquoi tu
ferais pas des maquettes pour c'est pas
sorcier lucas plus tard on sera grand ou
alors avoir comme prénom fred et jamy le
mec je veux faire les maquettes mon gars
mais direct avec c'est un honneur que
jamie utilisent des maquettes le blanc
ou noir
ok et le piège s'est alors mis le noir
vers le blanc et le blanc perle noire
non c'est pas le début d'une blague
raciste
leblanc j'aime bien le blanc à bages et
on préfère le noir d'accord perdre 500
euros ou volé un sans abri non mes mecs
perdre 500 euros dans ma temps forts à
tes conneries à très haute tension de
gens donc non pas du tout de race mais
alors pas du tout le mec aux mavs et le
bon sens ont de petites ont qu un rasta
blanc ou un punk à chiens une gifle pour
les deux arrêts stable en ouvrira ce
tableau moi j'aime bien ça me fait
marrer c'est drôle quoi le mec aider
dans le mauvais pays qu il aurait
vraiment aimé naître en jamaïque et dac
de ouf et du coup il fait tout comme les
gens que jamais avec sauf qu'il est
blanc et ce qui est retiré 80% du style
finalement un ongle incarné un oncle
incarcéré balou l'ongle incarné tu sois
n'en parle plus mais t'as pas envie de
voir ton plein car c'est un accord à 67%
des joueurs sur des gros bâtard ils ont
volé le sdf après pas savoir longueur
car ça leur en prison dans des quizz 20
ongles incarne un carnet on va te le
traité c'est fini on n'en parle plus de
semaine up donc un car c'est mon pote il
fait de la prison c'est chaud manqué de
pq manqué dentifrice beaux mecs manqué
de dentifrice ok de plus j'ai raté ma
ville manquait pq mon pote tu peux pas t
suivi tes baisers tu dois attendre le
lendemain on porte beau fond du débat eh
bien les années c'est déjà la fin de
cette vidéo se choisit un point fr
n'hésitez pas et bientôt ça vous a plu à
l'est pour une question là pour savoir
si vous faites partie la majorité aux
minoritaires vous allez peut-être sortir
très très mal si vous choisissez pas
comme tout le monde mais ça fait de vous
quelqu'un d'unique et d'original à la
place de michel dans le savoir regardez
[Musique]